[Music]
another day of protest by members of
this indigenous community in Northern
Argentina they have been blocking roads
for days protesting against a provincial
constitutional reform they say will
affect their way of life
Imelda belongs to the community of
Salina Grandes they're concerned about
some articles in the Constitution that
considers their territory state property
and could open the land for exploitation
we're fighting for our rights to be
respected as the original communities
that have lived here for many years we
want the governor to revoke the new
Constitution and to resign there are
roadblocks like this one happening all
around the province lithium production
has skyrocketed in recent years as the
world is trying to move away from fossil
fuels but communities that live near
lithium plants are extremely concerned
about what will happen with their
territories and with the Water Resources
in this part of the country
the protest is happening in what is
known as the lithium triangle an area
that includes Bolivia and Chile the
region has some of the largest lithium
reserves in the world for decades
indigenous communities have survived of
their cattle tourism and salt but now
they say their way of life is at risk
solida lives in the Lipan Community it
is right here where the lithium
exploitation could soon begin
all this conflict is happening here it's
unusual for us we are not used to this
and we're so afraid they want to change
laws and as usual we won't have any
rights
the province has awarded an area of 11
000 hectares to a Lithium company by law
the government is supposed to consult
communities in the area whether they
want lithium companies to operate in the
region
lawyers say the consultation did not
take place
it's not meeting with one or two people
and having them sign a paper there's a
standard and a procedure and control
mechanisms of how this consultation
should take place
form has sparked a violence that has not
been seen in years in this Northern
Argentinian province recently the
Government tried to move the protesters
by force dozens of people were injured
Governor Gerardo Morales says he has put
two of the articles that are of concern
to the indigenous communities on hold
we have gone to the community and if
they think we will run them over we
won't we have gone back to the two
articles that concern them and we will
revise them
communities remain on the alert they say
vigilance is what will protect them
they're certain that development in the
region will come at their expense
foreign